[Musique]
on est mardi et 23 heures
la journée est terminée aujourd'hui
c'était une journée tout ce qu'il ya de
plus banal une journée de vacances à
profiter des siens de sa famille une
journée calme voilà comment ça a
commencé
[Musique]
c'est incroyable nombre de saloperies
qu'on jette alors être bon je n'aurais
peut-être pas dû commencer par le plan
des poubelles c'est pas grave j'ai
profité de cette journée pour aller
rejoindre ma soeur mon beau frère mon
neveu ma nièce on était ce faire une
balade j'ai découvert un endroit
complètement dingue pour vous peut-être
pas pour moi complètement incroyable une
boutique de jeux vidéo qui ressemble
plus au magasin de gremlins où ils ont
trouvé le mot gouaille d'espèces de
caverne d'ali baba où on voyage dans le
temps un magasin complètement dingue où
on va retrouver les vieux jeux d'époque
je suis tombé sur ma super nintendo sur
les première gameboy même sur les atari
les vieux jeux atari d'époque
je vous emmène avec moi en faire un
petit voyage dans le temps vous allez
voir c'est quand même assez dingue
[Musique]
on est le mardi 27 décembre 2007
non
[Musique]
incroyable tout ce qui est ici
une journée tous cas plus banal sajoo
elysées une journée promenade une
journée pour profiter sous le soleil
avec des moments de relaxe rien qu'à
nous et pourquoi pas entrer un tour de
grande roue
[Musique]
ah ça monte ça monte ça monte ça monte
ça monte
on ya quoi 30 mètres l'a fait flipper
ces trucs c'est calme incroyable ça va
quand même vite un truc hein j'avais pas
qu'ils avaient un mode turbo sur les
grandes roubles soit ça quand même super
du temps y'a pas à dire tout en haut de
la grande roue c'est quand même
impressionnant on reparle un gros mot là
là on est à trente mètres non non ne
riez pas trompeurs
le cabinet
[Musique]
on sait coup la grand roue mais ça fait
peur mais au final dans ces journées
banal qu'est ce qui est plus sympa c'est
de pouvoir rentrer chez soi de profiter
d'être avec les siens sur des tout
petits moments des petits moments à
saisir savez ces petits moments qu'elles
ont repensé plus tard ces petits moments
quand on se remémore quand on en a
besoin dans lequel on aime bien
replonger le fida l'instant ces petits
moments qui sont précieux les petits
moments tout bête comme installer les
jeunes noël de son enfant c'est con mais
c'est des super moments
[Musique]
ce qu elles plus compliquées à noël
c'est le montage des jouets aujourd'hui
je vous ai montré des tout petits
moments des petits moments de rien du
tout des petits moments pas forcément
complètement dingue mais ces petits
moments là ils sont chers j'aime les
livres alors autant les partager avec
vous ah oui j'oubliais on parte on est
vite fait aux choses un petit peu moins
sentimentale on a un jeu concours me
semble-t-il
le grand problème des fêtes de noël ça
reste les bonbons super bon montrant 5
kilos à chaque fois merci à tous pour
votre participation
déjà d'aujourd'hui pour le concours qui
a été lancé souvenez vous il est annoncé
sur une vidéo vous allez gagner un
parfum diesel bad parfois qui déchire
j'ai même je vous rappelle les modalités
pour gagner c'est hyper simple vous vous
abonner à la chaîne voo laïque et la
vidéo vous la commenter et vous la
partagez celui qui aura le plus de
commentaires c'est celui qui repartira
avec son petit parfois et je lui
enverrai directement chez lui
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo avec tous
ces petits moments vous donne rendez
vous demain si vous aimez la vidéo vous
oubliez pas vous mettez des pousse vers
le haut partager commenter
c'est toujours un plaisir de lire tout
ce que vous avez remarqué merci et à
demain
[Musique]